[Applause]
logan paul goes eight rounds in the ring
against floyd mayweather and doesn't get
knocked out
it's crazy i did the impossible already
on sunday night the youtube star fought
one of the greatest boxers of all time
at the hard rock stadium in miami
gardens florida
mayweather was clearly the better
fighter as was expected
but paul utilized his huge height and
weight advantage to lean on mayweather
and avoid taking more than one or two
clean
shots at a time from the former
multi-division world champion
[Applause]
the 26 year old social media star
entered the ring
well over 30 pounds bigger with a six
inch reach advantage
and after playing mostly defense in the
second round
he turned up the offense in the third of
course it was known heading into the
showtime pay-per-view fight
that no winner would be announced unless
there was a knockout
but after the fight mayweather had
nothing but high praise for paul
you got to realize i'm not 21 anymore
but it's good to move around with these
young guys
test my skills just to have some fun
great young fighter
strong tough he's better than i thought
he was despite what would have been
a clear loss had judges been present
paul was still
pretty proud of his performance i don't
want anyone
to tell me anything is impossible ever
again
and while the crowd may have booed
throughout the fight looking for a
definitive finish via knockout
that moment never came and neither man
appeared seriously hurt at any point
the fact that i'm in here with one of
the greatest boxers of all time
proves that the odds can be beat i'm the
maverick
i go right when they go left i'm the
unorthodox one i'm the independent one
and everyone has it in them
floyd mayweather it was an honor i hate
being a kid i love you guys
i love all you guys it's one of the
greatest moments of my life
damn i'm happy e.t caught up with paul
leading up to the big fight
and he says right off the bat he was
ready to go
you hear that floyd mayweather wants to
get in the ring with you your first
reaction is
let's go sign me up where's the dotted
line like can this happen tomorrow
how does it feel knowing that you are
the one to pull mayweather out of
retirement it's crazy
i did the impossible already so i'm just
going to do it again sunday
easy and when e.t chatted with paul in
march
he joked about taking on mayweather in
the exhibition fight
i'm going against floyd mayweather uh
and they're saying he's pretty good this
guy
they're saying he's never lost these are
the rumors that i don't
you know i don't know if i believe them
okay so paul was clearly kidding about
mayweather's impressive record
the semi-retired fighter who competed in
five weight classes
stepped back from the sport undefeated
with a record of 50-0 with 27 wins by
knockout
i feel so dangerous i feel so confident
i don't know if i've ever felt more
confident about anything in my life
i'm a dangerous fighter man i've been
doing it for three years now and no
one's seen me fight for
over a year and it's all i've been doing
paul lost his debut professional fight
against
youtube star turned boxer ksi in
november 2019
but he told et the experience taught him
a lot you learn a lot when you lose
i i would almost be more afraid of the
man who's lost and is determined it also
has
nothing to lose like think about it i
don't have
anything to lose i lose against floyd
mayweather who cares right you fought
for mayweather
i win against floyd mayweather i'm the
greatest fighter of all time there's a
lot there's a lot of there's a lot of
freedom in that
you